and i want to welcome us
once again to the umix research
symposium 2021
um this symposium has been put together
to bring together
students researchers faculty and
industry to discuss relevant and recent
advances in omics data and
bioinformatics and so some of the focus
of this scientific graduating includes
learning about bioinformatics
and the cutting-edge research and
applications hearing to also get
informed about undergraduate masters and
phd programs in bioinformatics to learn
about career guidance and industry
internships and jobs and also
opportunities for bioinformaticians
that exist in you know in these various
and um applicable feeds and likewise to
equally look at opportunity at
discussing how um resources for training
and education can be made effective and
so um as part of these
um during this session
and under the omislogic africa segment
um we'll be looking further into the
changing role of bioinformatics in
research industry and education and in
doing that we'll be
moving into the panel discussion we'll
have some experts in-house
to help you know provide
perspectives to
you know topical questions we would be
looking um at
um
this afternoon i have with me on this
pane
um dr anita ganza who just finished
speaking with us
she is a fellow of
she's a fellow at the negotiation
memorial institute for medical research
ghana and i have
her the pleasure of having her
set to yet you know
benefit from her weight of experience
dr nita gansa you're welcome
thank you for having me
thank you very much also i have with me
um doctor vocatory
she is the chief executive officer
biology support service nigeria and
she is the founder of the organization
and she is actually very passionate
about biosciences and capacity building
in biotech as well as the business of
biotechnology and how to harness um the
untapped opportunities especially in the
nigerian and bioeconomy doctor toy
you're welcome on set
hello doctor toy are you there
yes good afternoon thank you so much
good afternoon we are happy to have you
um i have also with me hamza um mr hamza
sunny
he is a data scientist and fellow of the
medical laboratory science council of
nigeria and
he is the data science enthusiast with
king interest in using bioinformatics
research to answer biological questions
around blood parasites and infections
[Music]
i like to also mention that mr hamza
currently serves as the quality health
safety and environment executive for
afloat limited which is an aviation and
fueling company in nigeria mr hamza we
are
pleased to have you are you on set
definitely good afternoon it's nice
being on ground
thank you very much
okay um last but not the least and we
have also on set um dr adrian luzer
um liza is a researcher a lecturer and a
business development um expert in ages
and about technology from the south um
africa um
and she's also her lord you know sorry
she's also a sales professional a
commercial lead for illumina in 12
countries over the center um southern
africa i'm sure we know illumina a lot
um it's one of the platform that is very
i mean reputable for you know what we
are here talking about when we talk
about um ngs that's ninja um
narration sequencing all right so um
again he's also an independent
non-executive member of omix data
solutions um you know proprietary
limited and um she is a freelance
scientific editor
medicine with cactus communications
incorporated and also she is the founder
and co-director of contemporary africans
mentoring in not-for-profit and military
company
we are very pleased to have dr adrian
lisa with us dr lisa are you there
yes i am thank you very much for having
me
great great thank you all for for being
here i myself i'm adequately we like i
introduced before i'm the program
director for miss logic african faculty
with leed city university here in
nigeria
i'm a principal partner at eureka and
also the program director for miss logic
africa and i'm privileged to lead to
head tech startup as its founder and ceo
and they are praying and screened and
i'm also a faculty with um you know lake
city university in nigeria so
it's my pleasure being here today to
madrid this session
um without wasting time uh like us to
move on um as i introduced earlier on uh
we've been moderating this session and
i'm honored to have all our panelists on
board
and what we'll be looking at is
bioinformatics needs and training africa
as we all know bioinformatics today is
shaping scientific research and helping
us to derive more information and
knowledge about genes and their
functions and also in finding its
application to various human diseases
and such as cancer zema diabetes and
just to mention a few okay um it has
aided research in evolutionary processed
by a line compression of dna sequences
sharing of data
prediction of
you know future evolution and
classification of you know complex
evolutionary processes and so um
diffusion also holds a lot for
bioinformatics in that it is going to
help us to obtain crucial management
decisions on drug discovery just like
someone asked you know ella from one of
the sections okay and
it is going to be something that is not
going to
i mean
left to the domain of biology alone but
also bioinformatics
bioinformaticians and
using their bioinformatics tools and
knowledge would be playing a key role in
this aspect and that is why we want to
in this session discuss around
bioinformatics needs and training
um in setting all right and so without
further ado i want to
move straight to my first question which
i would like dr anita to please um you
know open the floor okay so my question
would be how has um bioinformatics as a
feed developed you know in africa all
right and how does it continue to evolve
and what are some of the
major challenges you know moving forward
and brought especially brought about as
a result of the recent pandemic
all right um dr anita would you open the
floor with that
yeah thank you very much
i i think that the past um 15
or so years has seen
a growing interest in bioinformatics
across africa
i remember around 2009
i personally was the only person talking
about bioinformatics at
my institution when
um i returned from school i mean it was
so far-fetched but today
everybody
knows the need for bioinformatics and
what comes to mind
is the
h3 africa
initiative by the national institute of
health of the usa
that has funded um
bioinformatics support the h3 africa is
a human heritage and health um grant
support for
human genetics in africa
and out of this grant is the
h3 africa bionet
and this
bionic for the past 20 years has
extensively trained africans in
bioinformatics mainly in the southern
part of africa
but countries across africa including
ghana nigeria and tunisia egypt
southern africa across africa have
benefited from this training
but
there is still a huge gap there still
remains this very huge gap in
bioinformatics training and for me
the pandemic has been a blessing in
disguise
we took the silver lining
of this pandemic and
online training online training in
bioinformatics is something that's shut
up during this pandemic and i think
that's
um
that is what i would say to start with
thank you
thank you very much for for that thank
you very much um i i i like dr voki to
equally i mean we in on that question um
you know talking about what are some of
those major challenges brought by the
pandemic of course i'm looking at it
from the perspective of how
bioinformatics is actually involving the
in the african continent
dr volke please
yeah thank you thank you so much
adequately and um thank you for your
contribution
that's why
okay um yes
bioinformatics um
even though it's been around for quite a
while
we're only beginning to
um get things going on here
in africa
i first heard about bioinformatics
during my master's in the year 2003
and it's quite new to me
and and i felt that that it was
something that was
uh very necessary
with the kind of data that was coming
out with me from the human uh genome
product projects and other
uh sequencing project
um
coming
um moving forward
and then get coming getting to do some
studies here in nigeria
realized that we really didn't have
um even the plan
on how we were going to
move
bioinformatics you know
uh forward here in nigeria
and i think that was also because
even our
genomics hadn't even picked up
because it's very difficult to talk
about bioinformatics
without genomics and understanding the
basis of this data
so you would really just be you know
struggling
to figure out what is going on
okay
so um the challenges are are
many and they're quite deep-rooted
we have gaps in our training that's very
obvious across universities
and
um also gaps in having the right people
to teach
so when we don't have the right people
to teach
then it is difficult to pass on the
knowledge
so we still struggle a lot with that
and so um some of the things that
you will notice is that there have been
quite a bit of efforts from different
groups dranita has mentioned hatred
africa who have been very very very
instrumental in uh bridging the gaps in
training
we've had a couple of a group called the
nigerian bioinformatics network i don't
know if you know that so
i've been part of them as well trying to
increase awareness and get people
uh to realize the need and importance of
bioinformatics
we held the conferences in 2019
prior to this we've had
some supports and partnerships with
global health workshop
the university of calgary
and this has helped in first of all
training
our students at the university of lagos
and uh this um other communities
in genomics techniques
and how and also with basic
bioinformatics
these gaps are still there we find that
even when we have some of these
trainings
the students are eager to learn and all
but suddenly once they come in
um the gaps
that are there make it difficult for
them to
um you know move forward and you just
find out that oh when you started
training with about 50 to 100 people
by the end of the training of of three
months you probably just have maybe a
handful
and
you realize that they just couldn't flow
okay
so
we uh we need to find a way to address
these challenges of getting
the younger generation or the current
generation to
be um
able to fit into it into these trainings
or have that
uh basic background to enable them
um
get the best
out of the uh trainings that we are
beginning to bring in right now
so bad factors have moved from where we
were
10 years ago now we are talking about
multi-omics
we are looking at
variations of data
and trying to make sense of it
so
it's a lot that we have to do and and we
just have to figure out how
we are going to get
our students
fully on board
on what you have to really do
thank you thank you yes thank you very
much for that thank you very much for
that um doctor
mentioned about you know the aspect of
you know
faculties to teach i mean to train um
interesting participants and equally you
mentioned the aspect of you know the the
bioinformatics in nigeria taking up as a
result of
you know recent grants and efforts how
be it
many of the participants get to draw
back i mean at the middle of the
training which points to the fact of the
need for basics well um without taking
much i think i want to also hear from dr
adrian and to get the perspective of
what is what it is like i mean from the
certain african parts of the continent
so
um would you want to see maybe in the
past a few things quickly regarding what
has been some of the challenges that has
been identified
okay thank you i will just add a few
because my previous um
co-hosts have already covered quite
extensively on this question
um i would say what the pandemic has
brought as a change is it has
enabled africans to see that we should
and we can be autonomous
uh when it comes to scientific
development
you know with the pandemic and the
borders closed and the supply chain uh
challenges that uh
came as a result of of uh the pandemic
we've seen that we've now become a
little bit more
innovative in our thinking
um but not only that the world has also
realized that you cannot isolate
um
[Music]
excellence in terms of technology so in
the past it was very skewed you know the
genomics technology
as well as the bioinformatics expertise
but now
seeing that you have to i mean should
anything like this happen and borders
are closed
the world has to keep going um
the pandemic the virus had to still keep
uh being monitored and surveyed in
across across the world to to to uh
prevent variants from emerging or at
least from to notice when they do emerge
and it has made it such that
the world is now invested in having
every other part of the world as
capacitated as any other
uh we can go into details on on this
aspect but what i'm trying to say is
there's been a lot of investment
in capacity building
uh
in africa but not as an isolation it's
actually a drive to make it a global
movement so that the genomics revolution
is not isolated in bits and past parts
of the world but it's actually uh global
in its distribution so that that will be
what i'll add on this question we can go
into the details as we progress okay
thank you very much thank you very much
for that um i mean
one key to go with your opening remarks
talking about how these you know
pandemic has not only as in has made us
to see why we should
the autonomous we can't actually be
autonomous and this um you know talks uh
goes down to the the need for um you
know us to develop you know
bioinformatics and you know all other
resources to aid in scientific research
here in
africa okay so thank you for that um i'd
like to move to the next question um
so um what are some of the applications
of bioinformatics that is most relevant
in africa today
all right looking at the various
researches on the various possibilities
from from bioinformatics so what are
those applications um you know that uh
we can really point to that very
relevant in africa today i think i'd
like to start from dr um
adrian again sorry uh permit me to start
that question from you
okay
um so i think they're more um
most of the research so when we talk
about bioinformatics obviously it
doesn't stand as isolation as somebody
previously pointed out it's it's
an arm to the genomics
uh research projects and priorities that
are currently ongoing
on the continent
and um from my perspective uh currently
the interest is
diseases mostly your infectious diseases
but also now with the
um
trained and growing uh prevalence
of of uh chronic diseases and lifestyle
diseases like cancer
and diabetes there's also a lot of
research on that
so
i think anyone considering
bioinformatics should not only
focus on infectious diseases and
pathogens but also look into
chronic diseases so then your population
genomics comes to mind
which is something that i believe still
has a long way to go in on the continent
but it's it's getting there um among
which really it's currently cancer
mostly um but we also have things like
cardiovascular disease
[Music]
rare genetic conditions as well
uh things like
sickle cell anemia and others
but that that is on health
and i believe most people sort of
gravitate towards health because there's
funding for health there's a lot of
interest in keeping people healthy but
we cannot also neglect um
the loss of
biodiversity that is currently happening
right under our noses so
africa being one of the most biodiverse
continents
we need to sort of invest
in researching and in following up
what is happening to our plants what is
happening to our natural resources
um in the oceans um in our forests the
animals so there is there are there are
a few groups that are also working
around that
um and while we are on the subject of
environment but also sort of cross
cross-section to health i know there's
also a lot of research around um drug
resistance but
in the environmental sense so lots of
groups and research uh uh projects are
looking at
antimicrobial resistance genes uh found
in the environment so in water
um principally
sort of to see how these are distributed
and also because those are easy easier
uh
samples to access and and study and
monitor what is actually happening at
the population level
um
yeah i think those are the major ones
that i can i'm sort of aware of and i'll
just let the other hosts um present
their perspective
okay yes thank you very much for that
response i think you practically covered
a lot of um you know aspects where
you know
magic is actually applicable a monkey
thing you you said was the fact that
bioinformatics is not cannot be isolated
it's actually uh you know has a lot of
connections with all of the women's
sciences and them
that is very very very um correct and
true um so uh mr hamza please um would
you
want to add to that um do you think
there's anything left out from what dr
adrian already mentioned
thank you very much mr dekule
i think she had
almost read out all those aspects that
is very very german
in addition to what she has said i think
um one aspect we are also looking at
lifestyle disease
and and that is just an addition to the
list of issues which has mentioned so
far
and as you as you know generally
speaking
we were talking about preventive
medicine now and then because
of people's putting dungeons and a lot
of things
lifestyles is the fact that um will
affect people's health in the
so and that
with comics generally we have a big role
when it comes to bioinformatics is
getting
things done in the best of ways then
most importantly
it has advantage when it comes to our
personalized medicine
with the just like we dranite
a question that you raised one of the
biggest things that happened to africa
is the pandemic
and the pandemic has opened our eyes to
see how
global the world is as being a global
village particularly and looking at how
we can be able to see how can explore
these opportunities around us
so i think the biggest thing that
happened to us is for us to look at
beyond africa how do you have access to
bioinformatics
training knowledge and application as
much as possible
and then just in addition to what you
said
just out of adam lifestyle disease is
just another addition we know about
cancer which has been ravaging african
lives but
with this this
content
all right all right thank you very much
for for that you know perspective shared
by you and i think you know just to i
remembered now the american god project
has to do with uh you know um sequencing
the microbiomes of you know the
participants in that um bridget and
i think a lot of lifestyle and you know
um
you know perspectives was brought into
that project and that goes to tell um
about what is actually
feasible when we talk about lifestyle
diseases as mentioned by hamza mr hamza
all right so um i think i want to move
on quickly to the next question and my
question would be what companies or
universities or colleges hire what
conducts and dm researches that are
related to bioinformatics particularly
here in africa okay we've mentioned the
history about it
and the h3 africa and projects and
elearning but are there additional you
know organizations that are involved
when it comes to you know
you know hiring or conducting and
researches that are related to
bioinformatics i think i want to start
out with dr
dr please
yeah thank you very much okay
so besides h3 africa
i would mention a few that are present
here in
nigeria
and um
starting with the nigerian institute of
medical research as you know that they
do uh um quite a bit of
research involving
uh sequencing of uh
certain genomes especially with hiv
which which they work on a lot
and now with the
um covid that has also come in
they also do a bit of quite a lot of
sequencing trying to monitor the
variants that are in circulation and i
believe they have cut a couple of
applications
in that regard
a laboratory biologic is also one of the
laboratories on the construction testing
for kovid and we work to work together
with other laboratories and this is the
medical research
uh
in uh monitoring the kovid pandemic
we also have uh
covenant university covenant university
is
home for um some of the
bioinformatics gurus we have in the
country
uh including doctor fatima fatima who is
in the uk
and then we have uh redeemers university
again here in nigeria that's in
where we have professor happy
and
on the private scene we have 54g
they're also working um on the
uh but on the private level and
biologics is also
working together in ensuring that we
have uh
we are building capacity
in this uh space
those are a few that i can come up with
uh at the moment perhaps the other
panelists can speak about this as well
thank you
all right yes thank you very much um
thank you for that i would want to pass
it on to dr andre now to
share a perspective i've seen that she
actually covers um i mean a number of
countries um you know with her
representation
from illumina okay but i'd like to
answer that question just before you
take that okay seeing that we have a
handful just as um you know dr
um okay already mentioned who are in
today's here in nigeria and compared to
what is um
um you know obtainable i mean what is
possible would you say we have a good
number of you know organizations
universities and companies actually
participating in that space
dr adrian please
okay um i'll start with your last
question um
no we don't there is there is still a
lot to do
um
when it comes to
for example
there's a growing interest in africa
as um
a data source
for the diversity our genome and our
biodiversity right
um however when you look at the database
where most of these uh
genomic data is being stored
you you are very disappointed when you
see
how many
are sourced or
are coming from
uh institutions in africa
or from principal investigators
of africa
and so there is there is still given
that we
sort of own the resource in terms of if
you're looking at diversity the richness
the power of discovery is literally in
africa right now
um the result the the actual work
and the capacity to to
get to that those answers
is is still very much lacking so
from from what from where i stand um
in africa i'll tell you that i won't
call specific names but i'll tell you
sort of where you should be looking if
you are a bioinformatician trying to
get a career perspective
um
you should be looking currently with the
interest of making
genomics part of a public health
strategy
you should be networking your ministry
of health
and there's a lot of
sort of
projects that are being um
conducted directly
by
your governments um and these are being
uh monitored or
uh
driven
so to speak by the ministries of health
now it trickles down to universities so
you want to look at consortiums like
those that like the h3 uh africa
and others that have been mentioned you
want to look at those consoles here and
see what sort of projects because they
do list out the projects that they are
working on so you want to see what sort
of projects who are the principal
investigators because most of these
people they now sort of play a dual role
of doing the data
generation as well as the data analysis
but the ideal
the ideal situation will be a little bit
of specialization so
someone people focus on the sample
collection and generating the data and
then the bioinformaticians
when the skill level is really at its
prime will then mine that data for all
the discovery that we are
talking about here so you want to look
at research groups in in those consortia
and then you also want to look at in the
private sector um because not all
your universities
um
and research groups have the capacity
to
um
own
a a sequencer for
for their research you do have private
core facilities
that have a number of
uh sequences in and of different brands
um
uh that they manage and so they generate
data for their clients and currently
most of them are not yet
getting into it but there is a big
demand
for these core facilities to also assist
the researchers with their
bioinformatics analysis so that is
another avenue you
as a bioinformatician can
propose your services your skills and
use it as a way of growing your skills
as well to assist these core facilities
to sort of implement this service to
their clients um
and
also you have um pharmaceutical
companies
um that are currently looking at generic
um
using big data
for uh identifying new drug targets
and things like that they are also
investing a lot in bioinformatics
currently so for example in south africa
you have a company called rush
it's a multinational company but they
are also very much invested now in doing
r d so in africa most of your companies
are not
yet
uh doing a lot of r d but it's happening
um and so you want to keep your eyes on
your ears on the ground for that um last
but not least i'll say you can become a
consultant like
let's have bio entrepreneurs that are
bioinformaticians right so you can start
your own company go to people one-on-one
offer your services and help out because
most people are really expert at
generating are collecting uh superb uh
uh
premium
samples preserving it and doing the dna
rna extractions and doing all of that
but then they cannot get to the
the discovery part of it that lies in
the power of bioinformatics and also you
have your clinical side of things
there's a lot of talk now to have
precision medicine
um
and
most of your clinicians they know the
concept but they can they need someone
in between the data as it comes out of
the sequencing or
and to come into the form of a report
that they can then translate into a
decision or a
counsel to their patients so
those sort of things and
i said last but not least but i'm also
thinking about
another sector that is growing which is
smart devices um smart devices that are
making use of
multi-omics data to sort of put together
algorithms um
to power uh
devices that will sort of tell you it
does don't eat those drink this don't
drink this medication not that one so
those startups are also coming through i
hope i haven't taken too much time
but yeah thank you
it's a bright future for bioinformatics
africa
yes i agree with you thank you very much
for that you've practically covered a
lot
about you know the areas of applications
and opportunities that exist in the
bioinformatics you know feed okay so now
i i think to to tie um
to that will be for us to quickly
discuss um you know around and the
educational and training parts all right
and so um quickly i think i want to
start with um
those who are heavily involved with you
know training institutions so dr anita
i like to ask um
you know how come is it that many
universities are not actually
invested or participating in
former bioinformatics i'm training
i mean they're not you know um
they're not they're not offering
bioinformatics degree especially um you
know the undergraduate and even
as it is currently in africa so why is
that so
yeah
thank you
thank you very much um
as we've been discussing bioinformatics
itself in africa is still very new
people are aware of it but
we haven't really integrated it into
what we do
as universities
individuals
are applying bioinformatics
in various capacities you talk to
almost every
student
they are analyzing some sequence data or
they've learned how to blast
data or something
but
we haven't gotten to that point where
it is actually incorporated as a course
or as a
program a masters or phd program i think
that university of ghana
the last i checked there were about four
or five um
universities in africa that had a
masters in
bioinformatics so it is
coming up but it's catching up and the
other thing is that those who
the trainers themselves
a lot of people africans who have
trained in bioinformatics are still in
the diaspora because they think that
there is no market for them
so that is another problem
and
some people what i've noticed that
people are shying away from
bioinformatics because
our training
does not give the
biologists especially that mathematical
that strong mathematical background to
be able to embrace
their thinking as a bioinformatician or
even
applying bioinformatics extensively so
the universities themselves must have a
changing curriculum such that anybody
taking an undergraduate program not
necessarily in bioinformatics but
any biology based program
must have some must understand the kind
of data existing now and how you can
simply understand it that way moving on
to either the master's level if the
university brings in bioinformatics it
will be embraced by the students yeah
all right thank you very much for that
um perspective um i i i think due to our
time we might not have um time to
discuss many of these further but i
believe um you know some of the
perspectives um already shared by
all the panelists you know all along has
and you know along and throwing a lot of
light into what we would actually want
to
expose the participants of the symposium
too when it comes to bioinformatics
needs and training
africa um there is a need for us to um
you know
move forward and hand over to the us
team now
to take their sessions but
i would say in wrapping up
that
you know after the symposium
we at bumislogic africa
would be reaching out to a number of um
institutions universities and also
welcome collaborators that we can work
together to to achieve the goal of you
know
scaling significantly the training the
training aspect when it comes to
bioinformatics so we look forward to
being able to integrate or i mean
partner with a number of institutions
universities to um
leverage our resources and tools and i
think one of the challenges i mean in
addition to what's and doctor nita
mentioned should be
apps
i'm
infrastructure
the infrastructures the resources needed
to
you know actually carry out informatics
um analysis
is um is quite demanding we are in the
in africa where internet is still a big
issue all right so as we move forward
and um you know having access to good
infrastructure that can drive
bioinformatics i believe we also um help
a lot of people coming into the feed and
that is one thing actually we um we are
proud of at mix logic africa right
because we have a cloud-based and
infrastructure that can help
participants to be able to conduct some
of these researches right there you know
in the cloud without um having to bother
about the space or or internet and all
of that
if they were to
stay so um on that note i want to wrap
up this section i want to
thank all our
panelists